MARC COHEN: Hello,
everyone, and welcome.
In this session, we're going
to build a web app together.
We're going to containerize it.
And don't worry if you're
not sure what that means.
We'll explain it.
And we're going to
deploy it to the Cloud.
And I think you'll see, as
we go along how easy it is.
And that's one of the things I
love about our Cloud platform.
My name is Marc Cohen.
I'm a developer advocate.
You can find my blog at mco.dev.
And on Twitter, my
handle is mco_ev.
And let's go to the workshop.
So I have one more
link for you--
g.co/codelabs/dev2prod.
So one more time, that's g.co--
g dot C-O slash codelabs--
C-O-D-E-LA-B-S-- slash
dev, number 2, prod--
D-E-V 2 P-R-O-D.
So if you go there,
you will see something
that looks a lot like
the window on the left.
And this arrangement
you see here
is what we're going to
use for the entire lab.
What's on the left is the
codelab that you should see,
and what's on the right of the
screen is the Cloud Console.
So I'll be able to go back and
forth without changing windows
today.
I invite you to set up
something similar to that.
But whatever you're
comfortable with is fine.
So let's get into it.
First of all, I want to just
give you some background
about application deployment.
And the key here
to think about is,
if you have a good
application, and you
want to deploy it
nowadays, there
are a ton of
different things you
have to worry about--
like provisioning
hardware, installing
software, security patching,
the economics of it, scaling
up and down, and so on.
It gets really complex.
And most of those
things are really
having to do with
infrastructure.
They don't have to do with your
application business logic.
And what I really
want to concentrate
on when I'm writing an app
is just solving my problem.
I don't want to do
all that other stuff.
And so what I'm going to
illustrate for you today
is a way to let Google take
care of all the infrastructure
for you, so that you can
just focus all your attention
on your application.
So let's get set up.
What we're going to do
is create a project.
So you're going to go
to the Cloud Console.
That's console.cloud.google.com.
And you're going to
create a new project.
And you can do that by selecting
this pulldown up the top here
and click this New
Project button.
This will prompt you for
a Project Name, a Billing
Account.
And in this Billing
Account pulldown,
that's where you can
select the free trial
account that you just created
if you're using the credits.
And then, you'll click Create.
I'm not going to
do that right now
because I have a project I'm
going to use that I've already
set up.
But that's what you want to
do if you don't have a project
you already want to use.
If not, you can
reuse your project.
The next step is, we're going
to start the Cloud Shell.
So the Cloud Shell
is this little widget
in the upper right-hand corner.
If you hover over it, it
says Activate Cloud Shell.
So go ahead and click on that.
And you'll get this window
or this tab popping up
at the bottom of your screen,
saying Provisioning Your Cloud
Shell Machine.
Let me make this bigger for you.
And what this is
doing is giving you
a login and an
interactive command
processor on a virtual machine
that was allocated for you.
So it's all ready to go.
And you already have
a development place
in the Cloud essentially.
To make this more
visible, I'm going
to change my prompt to
give me a little more
room to type on the screen here.
So that's your Cloud
Shell environment.
And you're going to
probably have everything
pre-setup the way you want.
But just in case,
you want to make sure
that your project is set.
So you'll run this command
gcloud config list project.
And you should see it displaying
the project that you've just
created or that you're using.
You've got that set up.
You can also say gcloud
off list as shown here.
And that will
essentially tell you
your account is set
correctly and you
are authenticated rather.
So you want to do that as well.
And if the project's not
set correctly, by the way,
you can do this command--
gcloud config set project.
And then, type whatever
your project is.
But you should be OK
with it by default.
I also want you to copy/paste
these Environment Variable
Settings.
This is setting the project
name in a short variable
that we'll use later--
the app name, the port name, a
default region, and something
called tag, which we'll use
when we containerize your app.
Last thing in this
getting set up stage
is we're going to enable three
services that we need to use.
So you'll paste those.
And by the way, when you
hit the first command
in Cloud Shell that
requires authorization,
you'll get this
little pop-up that
says Authorize Cloud Shell.
Go ahead and click
Authorize there.
And we're setting up
Cloud Build, which
will enable us to build
our project in the gcloud,
Container Registry to
store our container,
and the Cloud Run service.
So once you've
got those enabled,
let's go to the
next step, which is,
we're going to build our app.
Now, this is going
to be a simple app.
But that's fine.
We want a vehicle that's
not too complicated that we
can use to then
see it run locally,
or at least running in this
development environment.
And then, we're going to
deploy it to the Cloud.
So what I want you to do next
is click this Open Editor button
that I'm hovering
over right here.
And what that will do is,
it will create essentially
an integrated development
environment in the same window.
So now you'll have a terminal,
an IDE, and mCloud Console.
And what I like to do here is,
if you look at this bar then
I'm hovering on, you can slide
it up as far as you want.
And that gives you a little
bit more screen real estate
for your terminal and Shell.
And you can go back and
forth between the editor
and the terminal.
Sorry, I'm using
different terms there.
The editor and the terminal--
I'll try to use those
words consistently.
You can ping pong back and
forth by clicking these buttons.
And then, you always have
the Cloud Console up here.
You can pull this down if you
need to do more work up there.
So I find this to be
a convenient setup
for getting things done
in one combined window.
So let's build our app.
The first thing
we're going to do
is to create a
folder for the app.
And let's call
this folder Hello.
So we'll pull down
File, New Folder.
Enter the name Hello.
You can actually call
it anything you want,
but I'm going to
give it that name.
Do a little cleanup here.
Next, you're going to
want to create a new file.
And if you do that, it'll put
it in that folder automatically.
I think I managed to
put Hello under Test,
which isn't going to bother me.
But you'll hopefully
get the Hello folder
created at the top level.
So you're going to do
the Create New File.
And the name of the file is
going to be requirements.text--
that's a plural,
requirements.text.
That's under Hello, which
is where we wanted it to be.
We're going to put
these two words
in there-- flask and Gunicorn.
Now, for Python people,
you'll know what this is.
But if you're new to
this, requirements.text
is a conventional place
to put the required
packages for Python programs.
So once we've done that,
we're going to create
the first version of our app.
And I'm just going to copy/paste
this code under version 1,
Hello, World.
I'm going to create a new file.
[INAUDIBLE] main.py--
if I can type it.
And we'll paste
that code in there.
Let's take a real quick look.
This is using the Flask
package, creating an app,
getting a port number from
the environment variable
we set earlier.
This route is telling it to
support this Say Hello function
for any incoming
web requests that
are directed to the
root of the URL,
or the root path
you might call it,
and that come in with
an HTTP get request.
And all this is going
to do, this function,
is set a variable called HTML
to this very trivial HTML
document that says
Hello, World and returns
that, which will essentially
get it to percolate out
to the web browser.
So the next thing we're going to
do is go back to the terminal.
And you may wonder about why
I didn't have you save it.
These files will
autosave in the editor.
So I'm back to the terminal.
And as I mentioned
earlier, I accidentally
put the Hello
directory under test.
And so for me, just to repeat
that, I had the CD test Hello
to get to the stuff I wanted.
For you, you should
just see Hello,
and you'll be able to
just say, CD Hello.
So hopefully, I'm the only
person with that glitch.
Now, I've got my
requirements.text.
And what I want to do is
install the requirements.
And I'll do that by saying
tip3 install minus r
requirements.text.
And that's already finished.
And next, I'll run
my example app.
So with those two files, I
have a very simple web app.
I'm going to run it by
saying python3 main.py.
And what I can do now is
click this Web Preview button.
If you click there, you'll
see a preview on port 8080.
And if you do that, it
should take you to your app.
And there you go.
You have your very sophisticated
web app that says Hello, World.
So you can hopefully see
that working for yourself.
We're going to tweak the
app just a little bit.
And I'm going to actually skip
version 2 and go to version 3
because they're just
basically adding
a little bit of
successive functionality.
And I don't think there's
huge value right now in doing
each step one at a time.
So we're going to jump to the
end of this portion of the lab.
So what I'd like you to
do is go back to main.py.
I'm going to wipe
out what I had there.
Now, when you do
this on your own,
you can actually make
the changes piecemeal
because I've annotated this lab
to say this line here is new.
This line is modified, so you
can see the exact changes.
But for expedience,
I'm just going
to select this whole version 3.
I'm going to paste
it into main.py.
And just to give you a
sense of what this is about,
I've modified it so that it
takes a portion of the URL.
And if it exists--
meaning if there's
something coming
after the slash in the URL--
it will echo that
back instead of World.
So if I have slash Google I/O,
it'll say Hello, Google I/O.
And then, the other thing
is, it's playing around
with the background color for
the stuff that it presents.
So let's go ahead
back to the terminal.
If you enter Control-C
it should break out
of the existing app
that was running.
And let's go back to run
python3 space main.py.
And we'll do the same
thing we did as before.
We'll open the
previewer to port 8080.
And there we see the app with
a random background color.
The other thing I
wanted to mention
is, as I said earlier, you
can change a little bit
after to slash to
anything you'd like,
and you get Hello,
Google I/O. So we've
tweaked the app a little bit.
And I hope that
gives you a sense
that you've got a pretty
straightforward development
environment with both the
terminal and an editor embedded
right here into
the Cloud Console.
So hopefully, you've
got that working.
We'll go on to the
next step, which
is to containerize the app.
Now, I want to take
just a minute to explain
what containerising means.
If you imagine taking this app
and sharing it with someone,
they would need to make sure
they had all of the things you
have in your environment.
And the environment can
encompass a lot of things,
right?
One way to improve that
problem is to give them
your requirements.text.
But there's some issues there.
For example, I didn't
specify a particular version
of Flask or Gunicorn.
And let's imagine someone
installs this on their system,
and they have a different
version of Flask or Gunicorn,
or those packages change.
And the most recent
version works differently.
On top of that, the operating
system might have some quirks.
They might be using a
different version of Python.
There's all sorts
of possible ways
that someone who takes this
code could run into problems.
And wouldn't it be nice
if we could package up
everything this app needs,
all of its dependencies,
into one modular bubble?
And that's what a
container essentially is.
It lets you define
everything you
need to run this app anywhere.
The way you specify a
container is through something
called a Docker file.
So I want you to
create a new file again
called Docker file
with a capital
D. You're going to copy
this text into there.
And I'll just briefly walk
through what this is doing.
Think of a Docker file as a
blueprint for a container.
So it starts with a front line,
which says this is the base.
And that's a prepackaged
foundation for your container.
We're going to tell it
the working directory.
We're going to do everything.
It's the home directory for
the container/app in this case.
We're going to
copy our two files,
main.py and requirements.text.
We'll install the
requirements as we're
building the container.
We're going to set
the port number.
And then, here's
the command to run
when you start the container.
And with that, we can
build the container.
And we're going to do
that using the Cloud.
There are ways to do
this locally using
the Docker command.
But I'm going to switch
back to the terminal.
Control-C out of my
running Python app.
And I'm going to do this gcloud
builds submit minus minus tag.
Now, the tag is really just
giving the resulting container
image a unique name
in a namespace,
so that you can then
refer to the container
later when you want to run
it in the Cloud or locally.
So this takes a minute or so.
But what's happening
here is, it's both
building the container, and
it's pushing it to a repository
so we can refer to it later.
So now we have the
container bill.
We can say Gcloud
container images
list if we want to actually see
all the containers we've built.
And here's the one
I just made, gcr.io.
That's the container
repository, a registry.
I think.
mco Cloud Run is my project.
And Hello is the app.
So that container has the app
in it, and it's ready to run.
Now before I go to
the Cloud, let's
just run that container
locally, which we can do.
And just test that the container
works exactly like the app
did when I ran it
with python3 main.py.
I'm giving a couple arguments
for something called
port mapping, and that's to map
the port from the host system
from my MacBook into the
internal port in the containers
view of the world.
And I end the command
with dollar tag.
And again, that's
how I tell Docker,
that's the image that
I want you to run.
It said, unable to find
an image because it didn't
see a copy of it locally.
So it pulled it from
the Container Registry.
And now, it should be running--
although I was expecting
to see a little bit more.
Let's go ahead and
see if it's running.
And yeah, it is running.
So you can see that it's
looking exactly like it
was when I ran it locally.
And just to prove
it's actually running,
I'm going to cancel out of
it, go back here, and refresh
the screen.
And you see, I couldn't
connect to server on port 8080.
So just to review what we've
done-- we built an app.
We ran it locally.
And then, we containerised it.
And by doing so, we
now have this module
I can give to anyone
and be confident
that app is going to
run exactly for them
the same way it did for me--
which is super powerful.
Now, what do we want to do next?
Imagine we built this app.
It's a great app, and we want
to share it with the world.
But we don't want to
give people the container
and tell them to
run a container.
We want to just
deploy it on the web,
and have people be
able to visit a website
and experience the app.
So we really want to send this
app or deploy it in the Cloud.
Now, one of the great
things about the product
I'm going to be using to deploy
it, which is called Cloud Run,
is that it's going
to give you all
of that administrative
stuff that I talked
about at the beginning--
all of that infrastructure--
it's going to give
you that for free.
It's going to give you very good
reliability and availability.
It's going to scale
automatically.
It's going to minimize your
costs because you're only
going to pay for when the
app is actually running.
It's going to give you the
ability in one easy step
to add a custom domain name.
It's going to give you
security with standard SSL,
TLS, HTTPS type encryption.
And as you're going
to see, it gives you
very good response time.
So how do we do that?
Well, let's go back
to the Cloud Editor.
Let's go to our main.py file.
And where it says name equals
world, instead of world,
we're going to say
from Cloud Run.
So when we run
this on Cloud Run,
we should see a slightly
different message--
Hello from Cloud Run.
Now that we've made that
very small source change,
let's go ahead and run it.
Now, this lab says
to do a build/submit.
But we've already done that.
So we actually can
skip that step.
And we should be able to
just run this command.
So let's go back
to the terminal.
Let me [INAUDIBLE]
this [INAUDIBLE] here.
And we're going to run
the deploy command.
Now what this deploy is
saying is, the name of my app
is Hello.
That's the dollar app
variable that we set.
The image I want you
to use is dollar tag.
We've set that as well and
been using that when we built.
I want the managed
platform, which
is-- there's another
way you can use
Cloud Run, where you can
use your own lower-level
infrastructure.
But we're going to use the
higher-abstraction level
and request this
managed platform.
You can specify the region.
And Allow Unauthenticated--
this part right here--
is basically saying,
I want anybody
to be able to
access this website.
They don't need to log in.
And you can see, I
talked a lot longer
than it took for it
to deploy this app.
It's actually all ready to go.
Now, we can't just do
the local preview here
because it's actually
been assigned
a globally accessible URL.
But we can just click
on this URL to see it.
And there's our app once again.
But now, it's
running in the Cloud.
So if we send a lot of traffic
to it-- and we will later--
we can see that it'll
automatically scale
to meet the offered demand.
So that's how easy
it was to take
an app that was in development,
to containerize it,
and to run it on the Cloud.
Now, as easy as
that was, I still
had to think about this
notion of a Docker file,
and I had to come up
with that blueprint
in order to figure out how
to build the container image.
Wouldn't it be nice if I
didn't have to do that?
And that's exactly
what I'm going
to show you how to do using
something called Buildpacks.
So I want you to go back
to the editor again.
And we're going to, once
again, change the message.
Oh, I forgot to point out
earlier that the message said
from Cloud Run, which showed
us we were actually getting
that version of the app.
But now, we're
going to change it
from saying from
Cloud Run to saying
from Cloud Run with Buildpacks.
And in order to use Buildpacks,
we have to add one more file.
So under Hello, I'm
going to say New File.
And we're going to create
a file called PROC file--
P-R-O-C-F-I-L-E
with a capital P.
Go ahead and create that now.
And all that has to be in
this file is this one line--
web, telling it's a web app,
python3 is the environment.
And starting up
the app is really
giving it the equivalent of
how do I start the container.
And it's simply
python3 main.py which
we've been using all along.
Now with this one line and a
slightly different deployment
command, I'm going to get the
system to build the Docker file
and create the image
for me without me
having to work out what the
Docker file should look like.
So what I'm going to do is
actually delete this file.
Now the Docker file's gone.
And if I go back
to the terminal,
and do an [? LX, ?] you can see
there's [? my croc ?] profile.
But there's no
longer a Docker file.
And so now I'm going to
build the same service
and let the system
figure out how
to make the container for me.
That's going to take
a little bit longer
because it has to do a build.
But let me just explain
what's different.
Instead of giving
an image with a tag,
I didn't have to do that.
You'll notice there's no dollar
tag appearing in this command.
But there's this new argument,
dash dash source dot.
And dot in Linux
and Unix derived
systems is a shorthand
for the current directory.
So this is telling Gcloud, all
of a source for my app lives
right in this directory.
And I didn't give you a tag.
But I put a [? croc ?]
file on there to tell you
the minimum I need to tell you.
Create the container for me.
Build it, deposit it in
the Container Repository,
and deploy it--
all in one command.
So now I've gotten to the
point where I don't even
have to think about
a Docker file, what
it is, how to code it--
I can just, again,
create my app,
and deploy it to the Cloud.
It just makes everything
easier for me as a developer.
As I said, this
takes a bit longer.
So what I might do is jump ahead
to the next step of the lab.
And we'll keep an eye on
this window in the meantime.
So do you have to
use the command line?
Obviously, I'm doing everything
in this lab via the command
line.
And I'm going to just
increase the size here
so it's a little easier to see.
And the short answer
is, no, you don't
have to use the command line.
I used it in this lab
because it's easy to show.
And it's easy to
reproduce and copy things.
But there's three different
ways to use Google Cloud.
One is through the command
line that we've seen a lot of.
Another is through
the web interface,
which is up here at
the top of the screen.
And the last is
programmatically.
So you can use any of a number
of supported client libraries
as well.
So with that in
mind, I do just want
to show you quickly what
the web portion looks like.
By the way, this
finished building--
I think, yes.
And it's now deploying.
And it's done.
So we get another URL here.
And it's not going to look too
much different, except that now
it says with Buildpacks.
This is telling us it
got our new version.
So we were able to deploy
this version without even
thinking about a Docker file--
straight to the Cloud with
all these nice benefits.
So what I wanted
to show you here
is what the web version
of all this looks like.
So you have this
project up here.
And with the navigation
menu in the upper left,
you can go to the
Cloud Run page.
And you'll see all
of your services.
So here's the one
I just deployed.
It's called Hello.
And if you go to
the Revisions tag,
you can see the four
versions that I've deployed.
The last one is Hello
OOO 4 VIY, and that's
getting 100% of the traffic.
You can see your URL here.
You can get details
about the deployment.
Somewhere in here I can get
the specifics about the--
I think if I click over here--
here it is.
The image URL is
shown over here.
So that's the exact
container image
that we've built and
stored in the registry.
And we can say Manage
Traffic to actually point
a different percentage
of the incoming traffic
at different revisions
of our service.
And that's really handy if
you're wanting to canary--
like where you have
a new revision,
and you just want
a small percentage
of your traffic going there--
to make sure things
are OK before you
deploy it more widely.
It's also quite handy
for A/B testing.
So yeah, there's a lot of
things you can do here.
I didn't even show that
you can just create a brand
new service from scratch.
You can give it a name.
You'll give it the
container image.
You can set some
advanced settings,
configuring various things
like the hardware, how you
want the autoscaling to work.
You can specify a minimum
number of instances, and so on.
So lots of stuff you can do.
Pretty much everything you
can do that I showed you
from the command line, you
can do from the console
as well, which is great.
And you can also do
all that good stuff
with client libraries
programmatically.
So I'll let you read
through this later when
you do the lab on your own
if you come back to it.
Before I have you
clean up your work,
we're going to test the app.
So I want you to go back to
the editor/terminal window.
Slide that up.
Actually, I'm at the terminal.
If you're in the editor,
click the Open Terminal button
to go back there.
Let me make this bigger
and clear the screen.
I'm at the top.
Now, the Cloud Shell comes with
a bunch of nice capabilities
built right in.
Well, the Gcloud
command, for example,
came automatically installed.
And I'm going to use a
[? load test ?] tool called
Hey.
You can see what that
does for yourself.
But what we're
going to use it for
is to run some traffic
against the service
that I just deployed.
So here's the command
I'm going to use.
I'll paste it in here.
Now, minus q option
is telling it how many
requests per second.
So I'm going to
drive this traffic
at 1,000 requests per second.
Minus C is how many
parallel workers I want.
So we will have 200 parallel.
It's not really threads.
They're go routines
because this program was
written in the Go language.
And the minus z tells
how long to run for.
I'm going to actually
change that to 15 seconds,
so we're not waiting too long.
And the last thing I'm going
to do is change the URL.
Now, if we go back to
our Cloud Run service,
we can pick the URL
from right here.
Click that button.
We'll copy it to the clipboard.
And then, I'll just paste it.
I am unable to
access this window.
These things happen.
I'm going to reload
the browser and see
if I can make my way back.
This page is officially dead, so
let's see if I can resurrect it
in a new tab.
And if doesn't work, I'm
just going to move on.
But let's give it one shot.
OK, so here's my URL.
And let's go back to Home.
Let's make this smaller.
My Cloud Shell is not--
there it is, OK.
Let's move this up.
You can exit prompt
[INAUDIBLE] the screen.
Here's my URL.
Let's turn on
[INAUDIBLE] editing.
[INAUDIBLE] And let's
do this command.
So what we want is Hey through
the rest of the options.
And there, we finally have
the command I wanted to run,
except I said I wanted
to do it for 15 seconds.
So I just broke out of it.
So I can do it for less time.
Let's change this 30 to 15.
And let's let that percolate.
What it's going to do is
basically hammer on the service
I just deployed.
And it's going to
gather statistics.
So let's review what
it's telling us.
The total amount of data
was almost a megabyte.
It lasted for a little over
15 seconds, as I specified.
The entirely slowest response
time was 3/4 of a second.
The fastest was
186 milliseconds.
On average, it was
287 milliseconds.
Requests per second
was almost 700
per second, which
is not too bad.
I had ask for 1,000 per
second, but for various reasons
primarily related to the
hardware I'm running on right
now, I didn't quite get there.
But that's not too bad.
It shows a histogram, a nice
response time distribution,
to show you that most
of the responses, where
we had one outlier here.
Most of the responses
were fairly well
behaved at the low
end of the scale.
And the 95th percentile, for
example, was 567 milliseconds.
I'll run that one more time.
And the key idea here
that I want to point out
is that if you send
a lot of traffic,
Cloud Run is just going
to automatically expand
the amount of resources it's
providing in order to enable
you to keep up with the demand.
So it will grow and it will
shrink based on the traffic.
And this goes back to
my original comment.
We're doing the
infrastructure work for you.
You don't have to worry
about allocating resources.
It'll just magically
happen for you,
so you can focus on
writing your application.
This one, pretty
similar results--
so yeah.
The other thing I
wanted to mention
is back on the
Cloud console, there
is a Metrics page where
you can view the--
I won't go there now-- but
you can view the servers
that the Google Cloud Run
version or perspective of all
of the statistics.
You get graphics about
response time, latency,
requests for second errors, all
kinds of useful information.
So you can compare the client
side with the server side
and get some good
feedback there.
That's really what I wanted
you to do with me today.
The last thing I want
you to be aware of
is that when you do an
experiment like this,
you should always
clean up after yourself
so that you don't accumulate
charges after the fact.
So what you can do is run
gcloud container images
delete dollar tag.
And what that will do
is remove your container
that you just created from the
Cloud registry that you stored.
Now that didn't work.
And the reason is, if you
remember I ran into a problem,
and I had to
restart Cloud Shell.
And I lost those
environment settings
that I did right
at the beginning.
So if that happens to you, if
you have to restart or reload
the window in the
middle of this lab,
you might find things working
a little bit erratically or not
working at all.
And so in that case, you'll
want to go back and reset
these helper variables.
And now, I think if I go back
and do the deletion command,
I can just recall it here.
Now, it's got dollar tag.
And it's saying, are you sure
you really want to delete that?
And I'll say, yes.
And the last thing is--
I won't do this-- but you can
delete the services as well,
the Cloud Run services
that you're deployed.
And then, when you look at
them on the Cloud console,
you'll see they're gone.
So that's really the lab.
I just wanted to just
summarize what you've learned.
You have built a very
simple web app admittedly.
But you've containerised it.
You've deployed
it to production.
As we went through
this, you hopefully
learned a little bit
about containers and how
to build your own container.
You saw that it's nice
to know about containers,
but you actually
didn't even need
to know the details in order
to build a container thanks
to the Buildpacks feature.
And then, you saw how easy it
is to deploy this service using
both the Gcloud command
line tool and the console.
So now, your application can
be served with real confidence
to anyone in the world with
all these great features.
And the one question I
want to leave you with
is, now that you've got your
app working in production,
how many lines of
code did we have
to change to modify it
from the starting version
to the deployed version?
And the answer-- and it's
one of my favorite things--
the answer is zero.
OK, I did change
the little Hello tag
to save from Cloud Run or from
Cloud Run with Buildpacks.
But that was cosmetic.
The rest of the
code, I literally
did not have to touch.
And to me, going
from one environment
to another, more advanced more
sophisticated environment,
without having to think about
what that impact is going to be
on my code is a great thing.
And that's one of the reasons
I love using Cloud Run.
There's some resources here
for you to do more reading.
I will just remind you of
the link to the code lab.
It's g.co/codelabs/dev2prod.
And I'm probably finishing
a little bit early.
But hopefully, that
was helpful to you.
And if I can help
you with anything,
feel free to reach
out to me again.
It's mco.dev.
On Twitter, mco_dev.
And to find out more
about Cloud Run,
go to cloud.google.com/run.
And with that, I will thank
you for your attention.
And I hope you learned
something and had a good time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]